MARK: HELLO IN, I AM MARK
LEVIN, THIS IS "LIFE,
LIBERTY AND LEVIN."
WE HAVE THREE GREAT GUESTS.
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
AND MARCO RUBIO AND MIKE LEE
OF WHOM ARE UP FOR
REELECTION.
AND AS I TOLD YOU, WE HAVE
CHANGED OUR FORMAT.
UP UNTIL THE ELECTION, WE
WILL RETURN TO THE OLD
FORMAT AFTER.
BUT WE'RE STILL DOING THE
LONG FORM INTERVIEWS BUT
BEFORE OUR GIFT GUESTS,
MY STATEMENT.
WHAT IS THIS ELECTION ABOUT.
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT DIVIDED
BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP,
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT EVEN
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES RIGHT NOW.
DONALD TRUMP DOES NOT
HOLD PUBLIC OFFICE RIGHT
NEWER, IT IS NOT DIVIDED
BECAUSE OF HIM, NOT DIVIDED
BECAUSE WE'RE A WHITE
SUPREMACIST SOCIETY, WE'RE
NOT, IN THE DIVIDED BECAUSE
RIGHT WINGERS TRY TO OVER
THROW THE GOVERNMENT ON
JANUARY 6.
CLEARLY THAT IS A LIE.
WHY?
LET'S SEE WHY.
WHAT DO DEMOCRATS STAND FOR
AND OPPONENT?
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN DO THIS
IN AWAY THEY WILL UNDERSTAND
AT NEW YORK TIME, NUCLEAR
FAMILY, THEY REJECT NUCLEAR
FAMILY, THE TRANSGENDER,
MOVEMENT, ATTACK ON WOMEN IN
TITLE IX AND ON MEN.
ATTACK ON THE FAMILY.
THAT PARENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE
A ROLE IN RAISING OF THEIR
CHILDREN, THEY REJECT
NUCLEAR FAMILY.
WE SUPPORT IT.
WE DEFEND IT WHAT ELSE?
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE YOU HEARD THAT IS AN
OLD DOCUMENT IT SHOULD BE
TRASHED AND WRITTEN BY WHITE
SLAVE OWNERS, WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE ABAIL--
ABILITY TO DO WHAT WE NEED,
THEY ATTACK THE BILL OF
RIGHTS, FIRST AMENDMENT,
FREE PRESS.
THE FREEDOM OF ASSOCIATION,
AND EXERCISE OF RELIGION,
RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS DUE
PROCESS ONLY FOR DEMOCRATS,
WARRANTS HOW THEY WORK WITH
THAT AND TRYING TO GET
AROUND IT.
ALSO, THE 10TH AMENDMENT
FEDERALISM, IT IS SO QUAINT
BUT THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN IT
THE CONSTITUTION, WE BELIEVE
IN IT, THEY DO NOT.
EVEN BEFORE THE
CONSTITUTION, DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE OUR FOUNDS
DOCUMENT.
WHICH STATES WHAT REALLY IS
THE BASIS FOR WESTERN
CIVILIZATION.
NATURAL LAW, NATURAL RIGHTS.
THAT IS RIGHT.
AND THEY FOUGHT A
MAGGIVE IN
REVOLUTION SO WE CAN LIVE
FREELY THEY SAY WE FOUGHT A
REVOLUTION TO ENSHRINE
SLAVERY, THAT IS INSANITY,
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY TODAY,
DOES NOT.
THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES, IS UNDER
RELENTLESS ATTACK BY
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
REFUSING TO DEFEND IT UNDER
MERRICK GARLAND, AND BY
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE NANCY
PELOSI, ALWAYS TRASHING IT,
CHUCK SCHUMER, AND HILLARY
CLINTON CALLING IT RIGHT
WING COURT WITH RIGHT WING
DECISIONS, THEY WANT TO PACK
THE COURT TO GET WHAT THEY
WANT, STALIN BELIEVED IN,
THAT AS DID FDR, THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IN INDEPENDENCE OF
THE SUPREME COURT.
WE DO.
THEY DO NOT.
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THESE
THINGS, WHAT ELSE?
AMERICAN HISTORY, COUNTRY
WAS ACTUALLY STARTED NOT IN
1776, WITH REVOLUTION BUT
1619.
WHO SAID?
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IN THE
REPRESENT REBATES, FORGET
ABOUT THESE CONVENTIONS,
FORGET ABOUT THE SECOND
CONTINENTAL CONGRESS OR THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION WE
BELIEVE IN THEM, THEY DO
NOT, GEORGE WASHINGTON.
ONE OF GREATEST STATES MEN
TO EVER LIVE, THEY DISMISS
HIM AS A WHITE SLAVE OWNER,
WE EMBRACE HIM FOR WHAT HE
DID FOR COUNTRY, THOMAS
JEFFERSON.
WHO WAS ACTUALLY THIRD
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
WAS CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT IN
FOUNDING OF IN NATION, THEY
DESTROYED HIS HOME, WE
RECOGNIZE GREAT THINGS TO
THOMAS JEFFERSON DID, THEY
DEGREED HIM AND DISMANTLE
EVERYTHING HE HAS CREATED.
JAMES MADISON.
CONSIDERED FATHER OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
HIT HOME, IS BEING DESTROYED
WITH PROPAGANDA NOW, AND
JAMES MADISON TO BE
DISMISSED.
WE THINK WHAT JAMES MADISON
AND HIS FELLOW CONSTITUTION
WRITERS CREATED IS THE
GREATIST GOVERNING DOCUMENT
ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH,
THEY DO NORTH SO MADISON HAS
TO GO, EVEN
ABRAHAM LINCOLN, THE GREAT
EMANCIPATOR HAS
BEEN DENOUNCED BY THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND ITS
RADICAL ELEMENTS, WE SUPPORT
LINCOLN THE FIRST REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT, THEY DO NOT.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY REJECTS
A COLOR BLIND SOCIETY,
REJECTS.
-- THEY DISMISS MARTIN
LUTHER KING.
WE AGREE WITH HIM, BLUE
LINE.
THAT ENSURES WE'RE A CIVIL
SOCIETY THAT PROTECTS US
FROM WHO WOULD RAPE AND WHO
UL STALE WHO BUSH -- WE
SUPPORT THE POLICE, THEY DID
NOT.
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY.
WE CAN'T GET OUR RECRUIT
MENT, WHY?
THEY TURNED IT TO A WOKE
EXPERIMENT.
THEY ARE UNDER FUNDING THE
MILITARY.
WE SUPPORT THE MILITARY.
THEY DO NOT.
WHAT ABOUT THE CLASSROOM?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
FEEDING DISGUSTING
PORNOGRAPHY TO OUR CHARGE IN
OUR LIBRARY, PARENTS CAN'T
EVEN READ IT IN FRONT OF
SCHOOL BOARDS, CRITICAL RACE
THEORY TURNING OUR CHILDREN
DO RACIST AND DESTROYING
AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE HAVE TRANSITIONING
COURSES, WE HAVE ALL KINDS
OF THINGS GOING ON THAT ARE
PERVERSE.
IN THE CLASSROOMS, WE'RE
TOLD PARENTS, YOU BUTT OUT,
WE THE EDUCATIONAL
BUREAUCRATS, WE THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY UNIONS, WE'LL
TAKE CARE OF YOUR CHILDRENS,
AND SCORES HAVE DROPPED,
THEY ARE DESTROYED OUR KIDS,
WE SUPPORT THE CLASSROOMS,
THEY USE IT AS AN
INDOCTRINATION MILL.
WHAT ELSE.
ALL OF SPENDING, 10 TRILLION
DOLLARS SO.
>> THEY SAID THEY DIDN'T GET
EVERYTHING THEY WANTED BUILD
BACK BETTER WAS JUST A
LITTLE BIT.
THEY HAVE DRIVEN DOWN THE
VALUE OF THE DOLLAR AND
SOCIAL SECURITY CHECKS AND
PENSION CHECKS THEY ARE
DESTROYING YOUR RARE AS AND
401(K)S, AND STOCK MARKET
DROPPING, DROPPING DEAD.
LOOK AT GAS PRICES.
THROUGH THE ROOF! THROUGH
THE ROOF THEY SABOTAGED
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, WE
SUPPORT SOUND MONEY.
WE DO NOT WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS KIND OF DEBT AND
SPENDING.
BUT THEY DO.
WE SUPPORT THE DOLLAR, THEY
DON'T.
NEXT.
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
GOD GAVE US RESOURCES UNDER
OUR FEET AND
CAPITALISM GAVE US
TECHNOLOGY AND WE HAVE RED
BLOODED AMERICANS
WHO KNOW THOSE CREATE, TWO
YEARS AGO WE WERE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE NOW WE'RE ON
OUR BACKS, BEGGING SAUDIS
WHO SAY NOW, AND COMPLAINT
BEING CAN'T GET OIL FROM
RUSSIA, WE NEVER GOT IT FROM
RUSSIA OR UKRAINE.
HAL.
>> FOSSIL FUELS ARE THE
CENTER OF EVERYTHING.
WHETHER IT GROWING FOOD OR
PRODUCING PRODUCT.
OR TRANSPORTS.
IT IS THE GOLD THE LIQUID
GOLD WE NEED TO BE A
PROSPEROUS FREE PEOPLE.
WE UP SUPPORT -- SUPPORT IT
THEY HAVE DESTROYED IT THEY
ARE KILLING OUR
MANUFACTURING IN AMERICA, IN
PART DUE TO FOSSIL FUELS,
THE PRICE OF ALL GOODS IS
GOING UP, YOU HAVE WEAKENED
AR DOLLAR, WHAT HAPPENED
IN HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN.
THEIR JOBS ARE AT RISK.
AND SOMETIMES THEY FIRE
THEM.
LIKE WITH THE XL PIPELINE.
WE SUPPORT THEM.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY, DOES
NOT.
OUR FARMERS, THEY WARNED US,
THERE WILL BE A FOOD SHORT
SHORTAGES, WHY?
FERTILIZER COMES FROM OIL
THEY NEED TRACTORS
TO HARVEST FOOD.
WE HAVE FOOD SHORTAGES
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO.
WE WERE A NET FOOD EXPERTER.
WE EXPORTEDDED WHEAT, AND
CORN.
NOW WE'RE HAT IN HAND AGAIN.
WE SUPPORT AMERICAN
AGRICULTURE, AND VITALITY OF
THE FARMER, DEMOCRAT PARTY
HAS DESTROYED IT.
IT IS DESTROYING IT WHAT
ELSE.
THAT IS UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
BIG GLOBE.
OVER 190 COUNTRIES.
THERE IS ALMOST 8 BILLION
PEOPLE ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH.
SEE THIS?
SHE OUTLINE.
THOSE ARE AMERICAN BORDERS,
THIS IS AMERICAN
SOVEREIGNTY.
NO NATION COULD HAVE A
MASSIVE WELFARE STATE AND AN
OPEN BOARDER.
WE'RE OVERRUN
FOREIGNERS, WE BELIEVE IN
SURVIVAL.
OF THE CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES, WE HAVE
FENTANYL COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER, KILLING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF YOUR HONOR
YOUNG AMERICANS AND
DRUG CARTELS.
PUSHING DRUGS ON YOUR
YOUNGER PEOPLE, WE HAVE SEX
SLAVERY GOING ON.
AND RAPE, THE ABUSE OF
CHILDREN GOING ON IN THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IT IS
HORRENDOUS.
NO SOCIETY CAN SURVIVE THIS
WAY, NO SOCIETY IS DOING
WHAT WE DO ON ITS BORDER,
NOT ONE, NOT ONE! WE BELIEVE
IN A SECURE BORDER AND OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS, DEMOCRAT
PARTY DOES NOT, OPEN BORED
EOPEN SEASON ON -- BORDERS
OPEN SEASON ON AMERICA.
MOST OF ALL WE BELIEVE IN
THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
WE BELIEVE IN OUR HISTORY,
WE BELIEVE IN OUR FOUNDING,
WE BELIEVE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
WE BELIEVE IN THE ABILITY TO
BECOME MORE PERFECT TO
MODIFY WHAT HAS BEEN WITHIN
THE STRUCTURE OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE THE GREATEST
PEOPLE ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH.
BECAUSE WE CREATED AND
ESTABLISHED THE GREATEST
COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY DOES NOT
BELIEVE THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT AMERICA IS TOO GOOD.
TOO BIG.
AND TOO POWERFUL.
AND THEY ARE DESTROYING US
FROM WITHIN.
THEY DON'T EVEN LIKE THE
AMERICAN FLAG.
WE DO.
MANY OF US HAVE RELATIVES
WHO WENT TO WAR CARRYING
THAT FLAG.
NOW.
IT SHOULD BE CLEAR BY NOW
WHAT THIS ELECTION IS ABOUT,
EVERY ONE OF THEIR
CANDIDATES IS A RADICAL,
EVERY ONE.
EVEN THOSE WHO PRETEND NOT
TO BE, FETTERMAN IN
PENNSYLVANIA, WARNOCK IN
GEORGIA BEASLEY IN NORTH
CAROLINA.
KELLY, IN ARIZONA.
RADICAL.
RYAN IN HIGH, RADICAL.
AND HAS AN, IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE, RADICAL.
MURRAY IN WASHINGTON STATE,
RADICAL, DEMINGS IN FLORIDA,
RADICAL, McMULLIN, PHONY,
DEMOCRAT AND WHAT HE IS,
RADICAL.
LISA MURKOWSKI, SHE IS
DR